a
[Música]
el primer recuerdo que tengo de una
biblioteca sucede en la biblioteca
escolar de mi colegio cuando era
estudiante de primaria a comienzos de
los años noventas en mi memoria esta era
oscura poco ventilada poco moderna poco
atractiva tenía varias mesas
rectangulares en cada una que habíamos
cuatro estudiantes los anaqueles con
libro se encontraban detrás de un
mostrador ante el cual estaba parado el
bibliotecario un tipo joven pero molesto
en mi recuerdo que no lograba ganarse la
confianza de los estudiantes cuando
asistíamos en grupos a leer nos estaba
prohibido a hablar o emitir cualquier
ruido éramos como pequeños robots y
lentes en mi colegio también era común
que mandarán a uno castigado a la
biblioteca como consecuencia ya se
imaginarán en mi imaginario mientras
crecía la biblioteca no estaba asociada
con un territorio de libertad o de
disfrute sino más bien con uno de
restricción y castigo
felizmente años más tarde me reconcilia
con las bibliotecas y entendí que en
general es un error entenderlas
principalmente como edificios en donde
abundan los libros y cuya función tiene
que ver con la contribución que éstas
puedan tener con procesos académicos o
escolares en experiencia he podido
entender que las bibliotecas son mucho
más que libros muchísimo más son
espacios de acceso a la información a la
cultura y al conocimiento son de gran
importancia para la democracia porque
ésta necesita de ciudadanos informados
que la puedan sostener además al
permitir el acceso libre irrestricto y
en igualdad de condiciones contribuyen
con la reducción de desigualdades y
promueven la inclusión social
soy ese o neira escritor profesor gestor
cultural desde mi más antigua
experiencia a comienzos de la década de
los 2000 con la asociación civil niño
lee con la que hicimos acciones de
fomento de lectura principalmente en el
distrito de san juan de lurigancho en
lima hasta mi más reciente experiencia
como jefe institucional de la biblioteca
nacional del perú a lo largo de mi vida
he tenido la suerte de trabajar en
espacios desde donde he podido
contribuir a generar mejores condiciones
para el acceso a la información la
cultura y el conocimiento
pero también soy alguien que por lo
menos en las últimas dos décadas ha
tenido el gran privilegio de conocer
como usuario sistemas de bibliotecas
públicas de calidad en diferentes países
del mundo experiencias todas que no han
hecho sino convencerme de que las
bibliotecas son espacios de
socialización son infraestructuras
sociales que permiten y alientan el
diálogo respetuoso el conocimiento el
reconocimiento entre los miembros de una
comunidad
la creación de memoria la construcción
de identidad compartida
son también espacios como decía antes
que van mucho más allá de los libros y
de la lectura las bibliotecas públicas
son instituciones fundamentales para la
inclusión social porque contribuyen a
que las personas con condiciones de vida
más desfavorecidas puedan contar con los
recursos necesarios para participar de
manera activa y plena en la vida social
económica y cultural y que puedan en
consecuencia tener un nivel de vida
digno adecuado de calidad
permítanme que les cuente cómo fui
llegando a esta conclusión
ya les he hablado del recuerdo de la
biblioteca escolar y pienso ahora
mirando en retrospectiva que agradezco
haber aprendido tempranamente lo que no
debía ser una biblioteca porque cuando
tuve acceso a una de calidad fui capaz
de identificarla de inmediato
ocurrió allá por el año 2000 cuando tuve
la oportunidad de vivir unos meses en
maryland eeuu una mañana caminaba por el
barrio donde vivía y me topé con una
sede de biblioteca pública recuerdo que
una mañana muy clara diáfana de otoño y
la luz permitía que a través de los
grandes ventanales del edificio uno
pudiera ver con facilidad lo que ocurría
adentro
y contrariamente a lo que recordaba como
única experiencia en una biblioteca en
esta las personas sonreían conversaban
entre sí los libros estaban al alcance
de la mano y no detrás de ningún
mostrador desde entonces la biblioteca
se convirtió un espacio que visité con
mucha frecuencia
principalmente para prestarme libros
pero donde también pasé pasada tiempo
leyendo usando alguna computadora o
accediendo información sobre eventos
culturales o deportivos de la ciudad en
esas incursiones también pude notar la
forma en que la biblioteca era utilizada
como lugar donde enterarse de ofertas
laborales de oportunidades de
financiamiento de subvenciones públicas
de departamentos de casas en alquiler de
clases de natación de pintura de violín
también en el espacio en donde los
vecinos y usuarios podían interactuar
entre sí no solo en los pasillos de las
bibliotecas o de la biblioteca sino
también en clubes de lectura en clubes
trattoria en clubes de discusión sobre
actualidad política
sobre las mejoras necesarias que debían
hacerse en el barrio
pienso también en una experiencia que
tuve un tiempo más tarde esta vez en una
ciudad del norte de italia era una
ciudad adonde llegaban muchos migrantes
porque había cosechas estacionales de
diversos frutos los migrantes provenían
principalmente de países africanos o de
europa del este y en general tenían
pocas habilidades sino ninguna con el
idioma italiano
un día caminando por el centro de la
ciudad descubrí que había una fila de
unos 15 o 20 migrantes ante la puerta de
la biblioteca pública y al acercarme y
al preguntar me enteré de que estaban
ahí para inscribirse en las clases
gratuitas de italiano que la biblioteca
ofrecía a la población migrante
eso era pensé de eso se trataba las
bibliotecas públicas contribuyan con el
desarrollo integral de las personas
se imaginan cuánto mejor les fue una vez
que aprendieron el idioma a cuántos
trabajos más pudieron acceder la
biblioteca pública estuvo allí para
garantizar el acceso a una herramienta
tan importante para la plena inserción
social económica y ciertamente cultural
como lo es el idioma
mi experiencia recién reciente en la
biblioteca nacional no hizo sino
ratificar mi convicción de que las
bibliotecas públicas son instituciones
democráticas y democratizantes y que en
un país como el perú en donde todavía
existen brechas muy grandes que nos
separan entre peruanas y peruanos las
bibliotecas públicas cumplen un rol
fundamental porque contribuyen
grandemente con la inclusión social
de los múltiples viajes que hice como
director de la biblioteca recuerda
especialmente 2
el primero a la isla de amantaní en el
lago titicaca a más de dos horas de
viaje en lancha rápida desde la ciudad
de puno la ciudad del celular es
inestable es débil a veces inexistente
la escuela del lugar no contaba con
internet y su biblioteca consistía de
apenas dos o tres repisas en una vieja
estantería de inmediato pensé en el
modelo que desde los años noventas
operen la patagonia chilena y que brinda
acceso a la información la cultura y el
conocimiento a una decena de islas como
las del titicaca son poblaciones
alejadas y con muy complicadas
condiciones de comunicación pero la
biblio lancha durante más de 25 años
viene sirviendo a estas poblaciones y
hoy en día incluso les permite el acceso
a computadoras con internet esta es una
experiencia que debemos replicar para el
titicaca
el segundo viaje que recuerdo es una la
provincia de cutervo en el departamento
de cajamarca es una ciudad de difícil
acceso los aeropuertos más cercanos
están a unas 4 horas de distancia y para
llegar hay que transitar por vías que no
están completamente asfaltadas la
primera vez que fui puede también notar
la escasez de espacios de acceso a la
información a la cultura y al
conocimiento
cuando meses más tarde tuve el honor de
inaugurar en cutervo la primera sede
descentralizada de la biblioteca
nacional pudo observar como la población
se volcaba a la biblioteca como había un
gran interés por hacer uso de sus
servicios y como con el correr de las
semanas la biblioteca se convertía en un
espacio del que la comunidad comenzaba a
apropiarse y que comenzaba también a ser
valorada como un verdadero motor de
desarrollo
el acceso a la información es sin duda
una forma importante para que la
población tenga herramientas suficientes
para desarrollar una vida digna y de
calidad pero además las bibliotecas
pueden contribuir con la inclusión
social a través del préstamo de
herramientas que pueden ser muy costosas
e inaccesibles para un individuo ahí
están como prueba las bibliotecas de las
cosas en las que al igual que como
sucede con el préstamo tradicional de
libros prestan electrodomésticos
aparatos tecnológicos herramientas para
la jardinería instrumentos musicales o
juguetes de tal manera que la carencia
de alguno de estos elementos o la
incapacidad para adquirirlos no sea un
impedimento ni una barrera para el
desarrollo personal o profesional de la
persona pero también hay bibliotecas que
prestan semillas en costa de márfil la
biblioteca pública de irobot cuenta con
una gran o teca en donde se prestan
semillas de tres tipos de granos flores
verduras y plantas de condimentos además
de libros materiales diversos y talleres
y charlas a propósito de técnicas de
reproducción de esas mismas semillas
gracias a este trabajo muchas familias
han podido salir de la pobreza a través
de pequeños negocios como agricultores y
si no hubiera sido por la biblioteca
pública ese desarrollo particular no
habría sido posible
noten como las bibliotecas contribuyen
con la inclusión social al permitir el
acceso a tal diversidad de materiales de
esa manera la falta de librerías en
alguna comunidad o el precio de los
libros deja de ser una barrera para la
lectura porque ahí está una biblioteca
pública que te permita leerlo también el
elevado costo de ciertos software o
hardware puede ser una barrera enorme
para el desarrollo profesional
pero en muchas bibliotecas públicas sus
computadoras están equipadas con
programas informáticos que son muy
costosos y en otras incluso hay
impresoras 3d o estudios de grabación
las bibliotecas
contribuyen con la inclusión social al
incidir en la reducción de la pobreza en
la mayor productividad de la comunidad a
la que atiende en la generación de
empleo el crecimiento económico en la
reducción de la violencia del crimen y
en la construcción de culturas de paz
en el perú como consecuencia de la
pandemia muchas bibliotecas públicas
pusieron a disposición programas de
alfabetización digital para que adultos
mayores pero en general cualquier
ciudadano que no dominar el uso de
nuevas tecnologías pudieran desarrollar
estas habilidades
la biblioteca nacional del perú lanzó un
repositorio relacionado con los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible de la
agenda 2030 e incluye en cada uno de los
17 objetivos una amplia gama de recursos
de información
el proyecto quijote para la vida ubicado
en el distrito de puente piedra en lima
no sólo permite el acceso a libros de
muy buena calidad sino que también
recientemente ha implementado estudios
de grabación desde donde generan
contenidos que contribuirá con la
memoria e identidad barrial a la vez que
sirven para implementar nuevos servicios
bibliotecarios
la biblioteca comunal antonio gálvez
ronceros cuenta con el programa lectura
a casa que acerca y presta libros a
domicilio a comunidades de chincha y
pisco que históricamente han tenido un
acceso muy complicado con muchas
barreras a la lectura
la red de bibliotecas rurales de
cajamarca viene fortaleciendo la
ciudadanía de pobladores y comunidades
rurales y campesinas entre otros
materiales prestan libros como la
constitución política del perú u otros
dispositivos o códigos normativos lo que
ha permitido que muchos de los
pobladores conozcan y tengan conciencia
de sus derechos para que en consecuencia
los puedan poner en práctica
quisiera contarles para terminar algo
que quizá no todos sepan fue el
libertador don josé de san martín quien
creó la biblioteca nacional del perú
primera biblioteca pública de la
entonces naciente república del perú
apenas un mes más tarde de declarada a
la independencia pienso que esto nos
habla del rol esencial que la
institución pero las bibliotecas
públicas en general tenían para la
naciente república por un lado como
espacios que contribuyeron a cumplir la
promesa ilustrada de que el conocimiento
permitirá que los seres humanos dejen
atrás fuerzas tutelares y puedan tomar
decisiones de manera autónoma por otro
lado como espacios que aportasen
justamente con la igualdad de los
ciudadanos
pienso por ello que las celebraciones
del bicentenario del nacimiento del perú
como república en un contexto de
emergencia sanitaria nos ha permitido
evidenciar aún más las brechas que nos
dividen entre peruanos
por ello estos tiempos pienso también
significan la posibilidad de construir
un gran pacto social por las bibliotecas
públicas del país caliente la
construcción y sostenimiento de
bibliotecas públicas de calidad un gran
pacto que integre a autoridades de todo
el nivel de gobierno a la sociedad civil
a la empresa privada al país entero
volvamos a otorgar a las bibliotecas el
lugar central que tenían en el origen de
nuestra república como espacios vitales
para la promoción de la libertad la
justicia y la igualdad construyamos
bibliotecas notemos las de materiales
bibliográficos y documentales de calidad
que allí donde haya un ciudadano que no
sea capaz de acceder a algún recurso
esté la biblioteca pública para
garantizar el derecho fundamental
del acceso a la cultura a la información
y al conocimiento
[Música]